luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel and today me and my boys we're
going to go out survival camping
using primitive fishing techniques but
before we get started i want to take a
moment to thank
this video's sponsor grizzwiss
invented by survival expert and tv
personality bear grylls
grizwiz is the ultimate survival drink
and it just
might save your life griz whiz is 100
organic
all natural gluten free and it's made
from
bear grylls own dehydrated urine that's
dehydrated pee
that's right bear grizz will tell anyone
that in any survival situation
the first thing you do is drink your own
urine
however for most of us the thought of
drinking our own urine is a bit
daunting but luckily we have griz whiz
so we don't have to drink our own urine
we can drink bear grylls urine
all you have to do is mix one scoop of
griz whiz dehydrated urine powder
with any source of fresh clean water and
there you have it
instant fresh urine
after all you pee more than water so why
shouldn't you drink
more than water but grizzwiz isn't just
a survival tool
it's also great for rehydrating after
workouts and for passing random drug
tests
and now grizzwiz comes in two flavors
original flavor and asparagus also don't
forget to check out bear grylls new line
of survival bars
for a smooth healthy snack out on the
trail
don't forget to use promo code outdoor
boys to get this awesome griz whizz
survival flask
with your first purchase of any of the
new griz whiz products
and once again thank you grizzwiz for
sponsoring this video
enjoy the show wow
[Music]
oh look at this guys there's a bunch of
papa trees this is a papa tree
right here produces the largest fruit in
north america
[Music]
all right guys what do you think of this
spot
well we got a nice little spot it's flat
level a little dry
there's some firewood around well i
didn't bring a tent so we're gonna build
our own survival shelter for tonight and
uh
i'm gonna try to catch some food too and
i didn't bring a fishing rod so we're
gonna use a pocket knife and a bit of
line and
see if we can't catch something if we're
going to catch fish we need to find some
bait can you help me find some
earthworms
yeah let's flip over some logs
oh look at these hot darn look at the
size of these beefy guys
there's centipedes yeah there's some
centipedes down there
you find a big worm you got some worms
too
well that is more than enough worms
right there the nice thing about these
floodplains is the soil is usually a
little damp
just perfect for big fat earthworms
all right okay
got my worm bottle here you know because
we don't have a stove or tent we're
gonna be using a fire to cook off of it
to keep ourselves warm
so we need a lot of firewood and log
jams are a wonderful place to find a lot
of dead dry wood
you can see here this is a flood plain
so whenever that river floods the water
comes in here amongst the trees
and we get these piles where all the
driftwood
gets swept into a pile here in the woods
so all the fuel we could need
right here will you help me make the
camp put all the sticks right there make
a pile of sticks
okay good job
[Music]
oh that's a great stick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh look at the size of this leg look at
that
oh it's a giant leopard slug
you hold really still he'll crawl around
see his little eyes right there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you chopping that log yeah
did you hit your thumb with the pickaxe
here once you show the camera oh look at
that
you've had a rough week with fingers
haven't you yeah
he smashed his finger in a toy box last
week and had to get stitches
all right we got our fire pit and our
firewood all set up i think we need to
do some fishing
so i'm gonna go get me a fishing rod oh
i think this is it
is this a good fishing rod tickle tickle
tickle there we go that's a nice fishing
rod right there
so i got my fishing rod i've got a bunch
of bait
and i've got a spool of fishing line so
now i need to go find a hook all right
guys we're gonna make a primitive style
of fish hook called a fish gouge
and you can make them out of wood or
bone today we're going to make them out
of wood and you can use any hardwood or
even thorns
but i like to use bamboo and it just so
happens i found some
that is a piece of bamboo and that's
more than enough
all right that right there is our fish
gouge let me tie it on the fishing line
and show you how it works
so this is the fish gouge what we're
going to do is we're going to put a
piece of earthworm on it
and the fish will swallow it and it'll
slide down their stomach like so
and then when you pull it you get stuck
in their throat like this
hands down the best bait for doing this
is earthworms
that's how you bait the gouge you got a
little bit of a point sticking out that
side that side
but you see how the gouge is on its side
the fish will swallow that
and then once it's in his stomach and
you put tension on it the gouge
will pop perpendicular and stick in his
throat hands down bluegill and other
panfish are the best fish to target
with fish gouges because they just like
to swallow the bait for some reason it
just works really well on them
and a spot like this where you've got a
tree overhanging the water that's where
you're gonna find bluegill in the middle
of the day
in the summertime one of the keys to
doing this is you've got to make the
fish gouge
delicate enough that the worm will make
it sink
if your fish gouge doesn't sink when
it's baited up it doesn't work very well
we caught a fish there we go
the way you get the fish edge out is you
put a little tension on the line you go
down there and
poke the fish gouge until you get it to
turn sideways
there we go little bluegill jacob should
we eat him yeah
there we go got our tiny little fish on
our tiny little stringer
[Music]
you got poop in your diaper oh jacob did
you put your finger in your diaper
yeah and shampoo
you i'm close okay let's go change your
diaper
well i finally got the fishing dialed in
but jacob's a little fussy he's getting
hungry so i'm going to pull out some
snacks and then we might build a fire
and
work on dinner so this right here is
fruit leather made from autumn olives
that we harvested
here just uh last week you want some of
that
okay fruit leather is kind of like fruit
roll-ups
and this is made from autumn olives
which is a berry that grows here
tastes nothing like an olive it's more
like a cranberry
and it makes really good fruit leather
also i have a piece of smoked salmon
jerky here you want some salmon
yeah we caught this up in alaska last
month and smoked it
you like the salmon jerky okay
i caught it for you yay well we still
have a little bit of sunlight i think we
get our camp set up
hold on take your boots off
you guys want me to start a fire yeah
all right let's get a fire started
yay best day ever
[Music]
so i've got a bunch of wood shavings a
little bit of jute anything you watch
right now
yeah okay you hold this part
the middle part hold it you got it
watch out back off yeah yeah i had it
back away
you don't want to lose your baby
all right well we have a special dinner
planned tonight
you guys excited yes we've got
tomahawk pork chops you guys excited
all right
they were trying to eat your cheetos can
you please give tommy a cheeto
jacob you have to share the cheetos
jacob you have to share the cheetos
jacob where are you going
i don't like who you become when you eat
cheetos let me see the cheetos
[Music]
sorry bud well the tomahawk chops are
gonna take a little while to cook do you
guys want to eat some snacks in the
meantime
yeah okay how about some cheese and
bread
would you like some baked cheese yeah
okay
[Music]
see you guys have you ever seen these
it's a type of cheese called gouda
it's got the little bit of wax on it
all right so we're gonna put a little
gouda wheel on a stick here
why is it going to be dark soon
[Music]
i was like the best grilled cheese
sandwich ever i'm just
crackers about cheese when you toast the
bread on the coals it's super quick
and then you just blow them really quick
gets rid of all the ash
looks like we have a special guest
what'd you come in
we were just about to have some cheese
you ready for a campfire grilled cheese
sandwich baby
ready look at this
a little hot thank you really good
[Music]
very nice i'm getting pretty good with
that fish gouge
i think i might stick with the fancy
grilled cheese
let's salt them up
you guys find a giant spider
that one let me see oh yeah
oh put it in nathan's hair
[Music]
well mama's gonna head back home now and
try to avoid uh getting caught in the
dark and jacob apparently wants to go
with her so
he's gonna head home and me tom and nate
are gonna keep camping here and cooking
those chops
that looks good you know what goes
really good with pork
what apples this is homemade apple
butter
[Music]
we're gonna dip dip the pork in apple
butter
daddy i know i know you're actually mash
we picked two bushels of apples last
week and turned them into cider and
apple butter
i love this stuff man homemade apple
butter is the best
yeah there you go nate
some scales of meat
bluegill meat there you go after i made
it
these are madelines these are a french
cookie designed to be dunked in hot
chocolate
we can do what it's made for that is
ghost
yeah isn't that great
you guys full okay why don't we guys
start hopping into bed okay
well here we are guys we're getting
ready to sleep under our shelter but we
got to worry a little bit about
mosquitoes because they can get us so
bad when we're sleeping so i'm going to
put on this ulthrawn
insect repellent it lasts eight hours
and it's not made
with as much deet as other other types
of repellent so it lasts a lot
that's better real
oh who's get up and get dressed
well nathan decided his pants were cold
so he was going to wear pants today
i'm not really pants listen kid nobody
likes wearing clothes in public but you
know it's it's the law
[Music]
well i hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you want to see more camping videos
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
check out the link in the description
for our camping video playlist and don't
forget to click subscribe
because we put out new videos every
saturday morning thanks for watching
guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching